[Music]
this article specifically came through
the pipeline today for nick what are you
talking about dude are you
husband reportedly suspended on
instagram after vile death threat to a
woman what what did she say
what is she saying i thought she
was innocent all the time i still follow
him he's not well maybe he was suspended
but then i still follow him yeah
russians get down different you know the
dagestan native has garnered a huge
social media following throughout 2021
due to his rivalry with fellow online
personalities
i'm trying to like do a little better
you're flipping he goes
friendship with ufc fighter khabib
has even seen his fame extends to the
ufc world which saw him being guest of
honor at ufc 267 in abu dhabi back in
october however it seems hasbullah has
gotten himself into trouble online with
russian reports claiming he's been
suspended by by instagram after making
death threats towards a woman reports
say hezbollah attacked the woman with
abuse online after she posted a video of
his sister
oh you can't [ __ ] with his sister can't
follow this especially if they're from
dagestan they don't play it like that
family [ __ ] is is pretty important over
there he said i will not leave this girl
alive until she apologizes to the whole
of instagram because she filmed the
video of my sister and posted it for the
entire instagram wow they play on a
different set of rules over there
because i feel like because they're
muslim that's like i think that's their
uh
in dagger saying that's like the
prominent cult uh religion and they
don't like to show like their
significant others
their ladies they don't like put them on
video or anything it's very like
specifically women specifically women
they like so they got to protect their
mother sisters i think i believe so i
don't know i could be completely there
is that the reason why he's so mad they
are russian and muslim they're really
hardcore like i heard plus dagestan yeah
and i've heard some stories of like
let's say you're a guy just whistling
smiling in a liquor store any older man
will just come and slap you and go what
what the [ __ ] are you so happy about
like if you try to shake there was a
there was a famous like videographer
that would hang around habib's team and
he went to shake
one of their wives hands and they like
pulled him off to the side was like hey
like you can't be doing this
you can only shake the man's hand like
no brother you're gonna do this so it's
like it's very they plant a completely
different set of rules wow well was he
like western or something and he didn't
know the rules and they told him they
were just like hey just so you know
everyone's hand out of respect but he
didn't know that you can't touch the
girls yeah yeah yeah yeah is that like a
one-time slide thing second time will
[ __ ] destroy your everything i have
no idea probably when we were in
malaysia they said don't hug the girls
unless they hug you so i'm like so they
could do whatever they want with my body
that's [ __ ] up
i didn't allow them to upset say i want
to kill that guy
oh my gosh
yeah because we were doing a meet and
greet and they're like okay so like the
chinese in malaysia they go through a
different set of rules because they're
not muslim but then if they are like
malaysian like locals or like native or
whatever the term is if they're malay
people
they're typically muslim and depending
on how conservative they are they might
get in trouble for hugging you if
they're unmarried women but they could
come to the meet and greet and just like
[ __ ] high-five them or whatever
that's like cool so we were just like
high-fiving everyone yeah what's up and
then like some of them will hug us but i
won't hug them back cause i'm like i
ain't going to malaysian jail
so i'll just be like one of these go
ahead hug me
i'm not even gonna touch the nah i'm
just go ahead okay bye thank you thank
you for coming to the meet and greet all
right thank you hug me okay bye
can't believe this guy was given death
threats
imagine getting a death threat from him
he's so cute brother he's a kid dude
trying to pick i try to pinch his cheeks
but then you know what's funny is
underneath that child is a 19 year old
boy yeah yeah
but i wonder how his like how mature he
is because he's only known to be
a small jack's off bro do you think he
jack sliver do you think he gets boners
come on man look at how horny webster
was
yeah but do they have the same disease i
think it's like he's the same
just because you don't look mature
doesn't mean that you don't jack off but
is it but isn't it a part of it like he
has to go through like puberty yeah
oh isn't that a whole different side i
mean how old were you guys when you
first started
uh i was in
fourth grade so that's like nine yeah
but he's i've been having
a body but i've been having a boner
since i was like five though
yeah i don't know
what sex was but i remember being like
that and then like getting attention
from girls and i like the girls with
bigger boobs because when we hugged it
was so much softer
yeah yeah yeah softer
and then you get the hug and you're like
oh damn these are nice pillows you
remember watching baywatch with all the
homies and then everyone has a dick and
everyone's pointing the dick at the tv
screen yeah nah but i do remember my
friends grabbing their dicks the right
answer we used to do all the time and
we're like i don't know seven years old
everyone with the boner sticking our
dicks at the [ __ ] curve tv screen
wait how would you stick your dicks at
it just through our pants everyone like
was just like four little waists just
all up like that
you guys are just like not really
watching we're just like hugging the tv
or something who are the other three
the homies that live on the street
i didn't know what jacking off was
you guys are crazy you guys remember
wearing short shorts like in elementary
like it's like hella short right yeah
yeah cause i don't know what jacking off
was but every time we would watch it
like that like i would go to my friend's
house and his brother would be like this
like he's only like a grade above us and
his hand would be in this side of the
shorts and you'll be [ __ ] dancing
with this damn just getting down get
down and then me and him would be
laughing like non-stop just like we
thought it was so funny he would play
with his dick when i was coaching a
bunch of kids all the time i would get
kids from like four to like 15 and all
the little ones they'd always be playing
with their dicks all the time and i'd be
like oh like stop like focus focus focus
we just glossed over the fact that joe
had a homie who had an older brother
who'd be looking at jonah's homie like
no no he's watching tv
[Laughter]
he was watching dude that just told me
like ha ha
what is he touching his date for
meanwhile audrey's like
it's like what's that wet spot there
he's a trauma that he hasn't worked
through yet
you should talk to somebody about that
[ __ ]
slowly unpack so like how has that led
to the rest of your
childhood how do you feel about your
father we completely glazed over that
how what's wrong with us i do i do
remember though like when you're like a
kid and stuff and you're just like
[ __ ] on 33k or some [ __ ] trying to
download [ __ ] photos that take 14
minutes you know to get like just a
photo that maybe has some cleavage oh my
god and you're sitting there no
guarantees well you don't know about
this no yeah internet back in vietnam
what's up
when you're a dude at that age you'll
jack off to anything you just wait for
you're like ripping you're like going to
barnes and nobles and ripping out
[ __ ] like britney spears or many more
pages out of the people magazines
you know what i'm saying and then as
you're downloading these like [ __ ]
photos slowly all the homies are like so
like kind of like sitting a little bit
more upright you know what i mean trying
to like put their like leg up
you know
just hiding their [ __ ] it wasn't easy to
get born back then dude it was like a
black market of porn from like junior
high on and everybody saw the same [ __ ]
yeah like because it would get passed
around it's like i got my dad's playboy
you know you go in the bushes and you
[ __ ] look at it yeah like [ __ ]
give up like uh pokemon cards if you
wanted to get a burn cd from somebody
that had some [ __ ] videx porn on it
gotta trade it you had a trade stuff it
was a barter system crazy wow
now it's like so accessible so
accessible it's too easy it's od i think
it should be harder like
yeah that's true it's gonna be a
scavenger hunt yeah cause i wonder how
kids are gonna be we've talked about
this before but like how younger kids
are gonna grow up and how they're gonna
have [ __ ] metaverse porn oh yeah
they're gonna be in the big feedback
suits and [ __ ] dude i don't give a [ __ ]
about them they're gonna [ __ ] lose
their virginity online to a bot
but that's what i mean you think they're
going to be like out in the real world
like trying to holler at girls like from
their trailers and [ __ ] getting [ __ ]
corn and they're going to bust down
their suits and stuff and there's going
to be electric [ __ ] robots cleaning
up their
oh god
that's just the way the future got i
don't know yeah that's okay i like the
future man i like the future this is the
whole story of a ready player i need it
i need to eventually that's what
i was thinking of
they never covered that part though like
i feel like we were missing out on what
happened that's that's
the next one that just happened
that's part two when part two comes out
it's gonna be crazy
nc17
remember that one movie i think it was
called a a.i but it was that kid
who's like the first ai child and he had
real feelings and [ __ ] and then it was
the future
and then um
he really wanted to be a part of this
family he fell in love with the family
but then the whole family who couldn't
have kids they [ __ ] adopted them
they're like man [ __ ] this kid we don't
want them anymore because they're able
to have their own kids now spoiler alert
and then the kid is like it's not really
a spoiler i'll tell you what part is but
then like he'll give you a real spoiler
anthony lee
and then like he got kind of abandoned
and [ __ ] but he's a robot with feelings
ah that that movie made me cry so hard
it was so good
wally
it was yeah while he's [ __ ] good he
was cute too so boring yeah but in this
world it was
yeah
in this in this world they have uh robot
prostitutes
yeah it was pretty cool do you feel like
you're related to that child who was
like an abandoned piece of [ __ ]
maybe maybe that's why i cried like a
little [ __ ] did you guys watch a blade
runner 2049 the new one with uh running
the og blade rider is way better the og
blade runner's tied yeah yeah harrison
ford definitely did his thing but uh the
the point of bringing it up is uh ryan
gossing has this obviously they live in
the future he has this little [ __ ]
computer thing and anna armas is like
this digital character that like uh when
you buy this projection hologram version
computer thing ai uh she can cook for
you clean free she's your your
girlfriend so you can buy this but then
anybody can buy it so like she just is a
ai
projection that can fall in love or be
she's like alexa but like exactly yeah
exactly in physical form right or think
about the movie like her with joaquin
phoenix
that one was crazy similar things right
in the future you're going to be able to
purchase like an ai and everybody's
going to have access to siri but maybe
siri is fine as [ __ ] yeah you know what
i'm saying maybe alexa is in physical
form has a hologram if you can change
siri's voice from like uk to australian
to whatever maybe you could change her
skin color or whatever and build a
relationship i'm getting a divorce then
that's what i'm confident the future is
at least gonna happen in geo
see you later we're gonna get alexa i
don't have to deal with that chola voice
anymore
you